branding them as human scum north korea
has long been enraged by defectors
releasing propaganda messages into its
territory
activists have regularly sent leaflets
by balloon
or in rice-filled bottles to float
across the waters separating the two
careers
the issue came to a head earlier this
year with the north destroying an
inter-korean liaison office on its side
of the demilitarized zone
and cutting all hotline communications
with the south
in a bid to restore relations with north
korean leader kim jong-un
south korea's liberal president moon
jae-in has tried to prevent the
propaganda activities
the defectors have accused him of
violating their rights to free speech
as long as kim jong-un continues to
threaten south korea with nuclear
weapons and to suppress the people of
north korea
we will continue to release our leaflets
under this new law offenders will now
face up to three years in prison
and thousands of dollars in fines it's
not known how
north korea will respond outwardly
president moon remains optimistic
as when he addressed the virtual un
general assembly in september
the republic of korea has been steadfast
in making relentless efforts to achieve
denuclearization
and establish permanent peace on the
korean peninsula
with north korea still largely isolated
by the international community
and by the global pandemic president
moon's options for reviving inter-korean
relations are limited
but by passing this legislation he'll be
hoping to at least
keep those hopes alive rob mcbride al
jazeera
seoul